I want to talk today about policy genius
and something that is really not fun nor
exciting to talk about and that's life
insurance and dealing with insurance in
general is not fun we talk about
different types of insurance on the
David Pakman show all the time and I
would argue that dealing with life
insurance is even less fun and in
general getting life insurance has
traditionally been I call it a horrible
experience some people might call it
nightmarish and I've actually talked on
the program before about my experience
where I briefly worked in the life
insurance field when I was in college
and I learned then and I still believe
people need it even many younger people
but it's just a disastrous process it's
not exciting it's complicated it's
frustrating and one thing I learned
while I worked in the field was that
it's difficult to make apples-to-apples
comparisons between life insurance and
even other types of insurance options by
design it's not an accident that it's
really difficult to compare exactly
apples to apples what you would be
getting this is not something that you
jump up and down about having or buying
but it's actually really important to be
properly insured and I recently had to
figure out a lot of this stuff for
myself it's always been a bad experience
I didn't want to do it I knew I had to I
came to the unfortunate realization that
I am an adult now and this is something
I've got to figure out and I've noticed
that Millennials are often even more
resistant to deal with issues of
insurance than other age groups maybe
not surprisingly and there are some
specific times when you really need to
think about life insurance if you have a
home or a mortgage when you have kids if
you have a significant other many other
situations where it makes sense to
figure out what life insurance options
might be good for you and what policy
genius does is offer something that will
make the experience better which is the
ability to compare more than 15 insurers
easily clearly online in under two
minutes and when you find the right
policy for you their system will
actually help you through the
application process
and their team of licensed experts will
work with the insurance company that you
select on your behalf and the idea is
sort of like Expedia for insurance and I
know nobody wants to deal with this but
policy genius does make it easier makes
the process faster and more transparent
I went to policy genius.com I put in my
zip code some basic information it took
under two minutes to end up with a list
of options and importantly policy genius
doesn't work for or with a particular
insurance they're an independent
insurance broker and they work with
companies that have at least an a-minus
financial rating so you get all of the
information all of the options and
they're licensed advisors will help you
through that application process and I
think many people in our audience given
their proclivities will appreciate the
policy genius doesn't require all of
your contact information just to get a
quote unlike many other websites buying
life insurance it's not gonna be fun but
policy genius has millions of customers
and many people reported that they
actually enjoyed the process check it
out by using the link in the description
underneath this video